okay uh we're here back on overtime
uh the fda banned jewel e-cigarettes
this week ah no vaping for the kids
what are your thoughts on this wow what
are your thoughts this is the if
anything turns me into a libertarian it
will be this particular issue they have
not only banned jewel a tool that many
many thousands of people who have used
to get off of smoking biden is now
saying that they're going to reduce the
amount of nicotine within cigarettes
ask any smokers what is that going to do
it is going to mean that smokers will
smoke more it is not the nicotine that
kills you it is everything else in the
in the cigarette so to me this is an
example of government trying to do the
right thing and menthol and menthol
right they're gonna you heard that you
didn't hear that they've been talking
about this for years is that a law now
does anybody know do you know any mental
i think they're at least been in dc now
okay so menthol cigarettes which
i mean
to me that's a
i mean that's racist
well that's what they're saying
i mean isn't it the cigarette that's the
blacks prefer it's the anti-racist
physician because it will save more
black lives
um well we'll make something illegal
which will give cops more a reason to
get involved with black lives
right um
but
i'm a purist i only smoke joints
and
but i know it's not good for my lungs i
absolutely do i'm not going to pretend
it isn't
and for most people because i don't like
the way that the vape makes you feel as
the stoner it doesn't work really oh it
does well
really you you never you never use like
a puff coat i have i i no no no you
couldn't have it
this is no you just get your hand out of
your friend
no
no that's not a puff cup okay oh no
you couldn't keep it in your like a
volcano like a volcano
these are things you can't keep in your
pants
[Applause]
it sounds like
sounds like we're on jeopardy category
things you can't keep in your pants
[Laughter]
vaping is safer than smoke right vapor
is safe i believe it is
fun but we're pretty clear
okay i and i agree with you about joints
there's something about a joint i mean
people who watch club random they say
you know bill thank you again one guy uh
i don't know this this crowd is very
strange
they're great laughers but they will not
commit to anything
they're really they're very cautious
good people
uh but you know they're like bill you
always have that club cigarette in your
hand
cause you know that's what we're smoking
there's something about a joy it's i
think it's it's some it's it's more than
just what it feels in your lungs it's
like the prop of it it's like the
i remember when i smoked cigarettes
there was
something about sitting in a
yes and i like to kick you up the upside
the head kind of feel when you the smoke
when you first get it kind of bang
and the vape is more like
but they also
they're targeting just juul there are
other companies that make vapes jewel is
the popular one oh really yes is that
right yes well that's because they're
trying to keep kids from buying jewels
right and that's the brand that sort of
teenagers know and they don't want kids
to get hooked on nicotine [ __ ] the kids
it's helping people quit smoking
but that's not the case with menthols
these are adults
where where are you what do you feel
about that
i mean yes we found that smoking is bad
right for everybody by the way we know
and it has caused both individuals and
the government who has to pay for health
care you know a lot of trouble over the
years that said there is something to be
said for allowing adults to make some of
their own choices right and not making
everything dividing us racially you know
like smoking's bad
bad for blacks bad for whites why ban
the black cigarette
it seems it seems just unnecessarily
divisive am i wrong
i mean really we could also ask why are
we calling it the blacks
because that's what they call it in the
paper
because that's what they say in every
news story
they say it's like overwhelmingly used
by black smokers italians do it too they
like menthol italians don't live here
no they're one time longer
the ones on long island okay
the minority cigarette yeah
they made one called one called uptown
once remember that
uptown cigarette and then and then they
had ones for just women remember uh
virginia
very long and yeah i tried doubled it as
tampons
[Laughter]
okay christine do you think tech savvy
millennials and genders will be able to
prevent their own children from
accessing internet porn
wow
um i think that the way that they're
going to prevent them now is by not
having them actually i mean
america is undergoing like a fertility
crisis basically people are having way
fewer children that's not a crisis
that's good
i do come on
if you're at all an
environmentalist you have to recognize
the main cause of environmental
destruction is there's too many people
and not enough resources and people
create pollution good news is that in in
the in the countries where which we
always thought of as exponential growth
it's actually coming down quite oh yes
in some ways this may be some natural
balance that essentially humans will
realize that they they survive they've
got to stop reproducing or they have
access to contraceptives why are they
just full of despair yes
yes they don't think that the world is
going to be a place that they want to
bring their kids into which is that's
right sad but every generation has said
that every generation has said oh i
can't bring a
child into this world you know it's
funny they never say it in the reverse
when someone dies they never go good
[Applause]
uh
mike pence claimed this week that joe
biden lies
what is this hole this trump person has
over these people
mike they tried to hang him and he's
still defending him i just don't get it
mike pence claimed this week that joe
biden lies more than any other president
he's seen
i can't i don't know
i can't even sure
all right i'm going to go right to the
next one in an interview this week
last one of the first half of our season
in an interview this week tom hanks
said hollywood wouldn't cast him as a
gay man today
oh philadelphia right and tom hanks said
rightly so
oh
tom always on the right side remember
but
do you agree with this sentiment i don't
i don't it's an actor right
what is this insanity
he might be right in the sense that
hollywood might not cast it no he said
rightly so that's the part where he's
wrong
i agree i think he's wrong
yeah there i've said it tom hanks could
be wrong
all right thank you everybody
appreciate you being here
you